et maintenant c'est quand même été super
difficile
bon moi je suis pas médecin je suis
infirmier mais médecin vous imaginez
vous regardez études super longue faut
mettre ses mains à l'intérieur des gens
et puis surtout vous chialez faire
d'erreur un médecin qui fait une erreur
ok la paye cash
c'est surtout les autres qui prennent
cher lors d'une erreur médicale qui ont
marqué les esprits hier celle du docteur
rolando sanchez c'est un chirurgien qui
a été jugé en 1995 en floride pour avoir
amputé le mauvais pied à l'un de ses
passions de 52 ans on se défend de
l'homme a expliqué que le personnel du
bloc opératoire avait préparé le mauvais
côté et que le membre en question était
de toute façon tellement mauvais état
qu'il aurait sûrement fallu l'amputer un
jour ou l'autre
c'est d'ailleurs sans doute la raison
pour laquelle il n'a pas pris le temps
de vérifier lui-même sur le dossier du
patient qu'il opérait bien côté prévu le
chirurgien a été suspendu six mois le
patient lui il était se faire amputer
l'autre pied dans un autre hôpital est
il décédé six ans plus tard en 2010 et
une patiente de 92 ans qui a subi à peu
près le même sort en autriche
cette fois c'est sa jambe entière qui
lui a été retirée du pied jusqu'à la
hanche par erreur ils ont tiré la
mauvaise enfin la bonne
loupé cb on est d'accord à confondre sa
gauche et sa droite quand on est
chirurgien c'est embêtant
alors imaginez quand ces trois
chirurgiens d'un même hôpital
c'est arrivé en 2007 à rhodes island ou
trois neurochirurgiens différents ont
ouvert le crâne de leur passion
respectifs du mauvais côté et tout ça la
même année
bon cette fois ils sont rendus compte de
leur erreur avant de commettre
l'irréparable
ils ont refermé et ils ont intérêt le
bon côté mais comme on l'a vu ça se
termine pas toujours aussi bien
la même année à los angeles un
chirurgien a retiré un homme de 47 ans
le testicule droit au lieu du gauche en
caroline du nord en 2002 une patiente de
46 ans a subi une ablation des deux
seins parce qu'on lui avait découvert
une forme très agressive de cancer
il s'est avéré après l'opération que sa
poitrine était en fait ce n est que ces
analyses avaient été mélangées au labo
avec celle d'une autre patiente et en
2011 à la réunion un patient s'est vu
retirer 1
en parfaite santé lui laissant que celui
qui était malade
c'est un paramètre dans ces cas certes
dramatique les patients ont survécu
jessica senti ain el al a pas eu cette
chance en 2003 cette jeune mexicaine de
17 ans a enfin reçu la grève pour
laquelle elle était venue vivre aux
états unis trois ans plus tôt un coeur
et un poumon qu'il était en réalité
incompatibles parce qu'ils provenaient
d'un donneur qui n'étaient pas du même
groupe sanguin qu'elle son organisme les
âmes massivement rejeté créant des
dommages irréversibles et malgré une
nouvelle greffe avec des organes du bon
groupe sanguin cette fois l'adolescente
est décédée
le cas de cette jeune fille est très
rare mais il ya d'autres erreurs qui
sont très courantes comme le matériel
chirurgical oublié dans un patient avant
que celui ci ne soit refermée est une
véritable boucherie à l'intérieur grand
classique les compresse oubliée dans le
ventre le personnel du bloc opératoire
et censés compter les compresses utilisé
puis compter le nombre qui sont jetés à
la fin de l'opération mais parfois le
compte n'est pas bon c'est ce qui est
arrivé en 2011 impatiente 72 ans opérait
dans les hauts-de-seine pour ce qu'il
pensait être une tumeur de plus de 16 cm
la tumeur s'est avéré être en réalité
une compresse laisser là onze ans plus
tôt par un chirurgien
parfois il s'agit même d'instruments la
même année à lyon une patiente a dû être
réopéré pour lui retirer une pince
oubliée dans son abdomen sept mois plus
tôt et qui commençait à ressortir toute
seule par son nom d parmi les nombreux
autres cas on peut aussi citer celui de
cette patiente de 34 ans qui a vécu
cette fois avec une lame de bistouri
dans le ventre en ile de france
mais la palme revient à un gynécologue
jordanien en 2015 qui après avoir
pratiqué une césarienne sur une de ses
patientes ne retrouvait plus son
téléphone portable
et pour cause
quand on regarde d'un peu plus près les
causes de ce genre d'accident on
retrouve parfois une accumulation
d'erreurs individuelles
mais le plus souvent un non respect des
procédures à un moment ou à un autre
pour gagner du temps par exemple
c'est l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
la course à la rentabilité dans le
domaine de la santé
c'est pas une bonne idée on n'a pas de
statistiques fiables sur les accidents
médicaux en france
mais les associations de défense des
victimes avancent le chiffre de 450
mille cas entraînant 30 à 40 mille morts
chaque intention là on parle d'accident
au sens large c'est-à-dire pas
uniquement des erreurs individuelles et
aussi des effets secondaires de
médicaments des infections nosocomiales
et c'est l'office national
d'indemnisation des accidents médicaux a
été créée en 2002 pour gérer ce genre de
cas je vous mets le lien dans la
description
je ne souhaite pas mais on sait jamais
ça peut servir
voilà détester c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui continuez de vous faire
soigner quand même la médecine ça sauve
beaucoup plus de vies que ça langage on
se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
vidéo
d'ici là prenez soin de vous prenez soin
des autres et surtout portez vous